I am oh I went to dr. Drew's birthday
party last week and dr. drew I don't
know if you know him he is a you know
he's a medical professional but he is
also kind of a you know like a chat like
he works with Adam Carolla's on the Adam
Carolla's show and they are you know a
couple of kind of Chatty bad boys and
Adam kind of talks like you about how he
knows everything but dr. Drew actually
does know everything so it's really fun
being around those dudes because it's I
don't know they just you know Adam
always tells dr. Drew to kind of pipe
down but dr. Drew's the one with the
information you know an Adam was a
construction worker and then something
happened to him or something and I think
he got workman's comp and and then
started podcasting you know but they're
both beautiful guys and dr. Drew had a
60th birthday party so I went over there
and Jeannie boss was there she was on
here remember Jeannie bus came in here
and uh-oh here's what she told me she
said that since she came on here a lot
of men been hitting her up on Instagram
and she even went on a date with one of
them so look at that we're making love
out there and I wanted to see if maybe
they had done a little bit of that you
know that my my my my my mom you know
that bang that bang bang but but she
didn't give me all that you know she's a
lady and she didn't you know get me like
that and tell me all of it but that was
like pretty cool like wow we had her and
we talked to her and then now she's out
there you know she you know she was
dating the guy from the Verizon shop
[__] she might you know she might date a
damn sandwich artist you know she might
date a [__] Quiznos chef next who
know whose bra there you could be
unemployed there long as you could
juggle and get her attention you might
have a shot with the beautiful
Jeannie bus but you know the party was
pretty cool I saw you know and I don't
like dr. Drew's kind of thing in his
wife Susan pants cos she's great man and
there
a beautiful couple and you know I'll say
this about dr. drew man he has always
been you know those people you meet in
this business you're like man this dude
is a straight Mulan you know this Mook
right here you know this guy's just out
for himself he doesn't care but dr. Drew
not never you always get the feeling
like he generally you know yes he's in
the entertainment industry and this and
that but that he cares about other
people and that he feels a
responsibility in the world with his
knowledge to help others anyway but dr.
drew man I've always gotten great
instincts from that guy and I've just
felt blessed even know that man and his
lovely wife we had a good time but they
had a podcast at the birthday party so
you want to talk to people in mill
around and they got a podcast going on
so you can go check out the episode I
thought honestly one of the worst ideas
I've ever seen in my life I'm like wow
honest well everybody wants to have fun
but they got a huge and the podcast is
happenin live and it was cool and look I
got to be I was a guest for you know
yeah they just cycled through gas and
everybody stopped in and said hey and
and it was nice to be a part of it I
felt honored and I guess it doesn't
matter what I think you know that I
thought it was aggravating because it's
not my [__] party you know I was a
guest it's his party
it's his wife's it's a their event what
does it matter what I I mean I you know
that's what sometimes about me out
that's one of the things sometimes I'll
be like Manny's [__] sucks who gives
a [__] bro you're a guest to somebody
else who don't suck this might be their
you know this might be their sing you
know um their magnum opus this might be
their uh you know kit and caboodle and
to you it's just yarn so but it was you
know it was a unique experience who else
was there
oh uh that tall guy with the spiky hair
who did talk soup Joel McHale he was
there Tom Arnold was there yelling about
Donald Trump did it was so fun he tried
to make it an announcement about Donald
Trump
at this birthday nobody gave a [__]
brahh and I would love to have Tom Arlen
here I'm gonna reach out to him and see
if he'll come on yeah apparently he's
been like searching on for some like
lost tape against Donald Trump that's
just everybody's just been laughing
about it I hear but um who else Stevo
was there that was pretty cool to see
Steve you know he talked like and I
don't know and that was a loss Oh Bob
Saget was there you know but it was fun
man I was honored to be there and uh and
it was kind of fancy to see no dress
enough and people are there and and I
just felt kind of honored to be a part
of it